POINTS IN SIX STRAIGHT.
WE ARE READ
HAMILTON W
TRAFFIC GETS IN FRONT OF HAVE T
SOMETIMES, YOU GET A LUCKY
AGAIN, THE NET FRONT IS THERE C
THE FRONT.
WE HAVE SEEN THIS SO MANY TIMES
OVER THE SEASON, THE E  GETS IT
DOMI.
A SNAPSHOT PUT ON. PERIOD . HE
TEXTED HOME.CONTROLLED FOUR
CHECK HERE.
GETS PICKED OFF WITH
ABSOLUTELY ROCKETED SHOT. HE MI
JERSEY WITH A  HAMMOND!MERCER S
ANTII RAANTA
LOCK IT UP HERE.
WALKING TO THE ZONE
BOUNCING PUCK, AS THAT WAS
CHOPPED FROM THE BOARDS.
THE ROOKIE WAS DAZZLING THE
IT TO STEVEN LORENTZ.
HE GETS A NICE .  WE SEE BRADYZ
CONNECTS THE DOTS.
ZONE.
THE DEVIVITHE HARVARD MAN, WITH
JIMMY VESEY CAPITALIZES, NOT T